brought to you by total war warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free this week you're spending
your last time in Tucson because we're
getting the final dlc for The Witcher
it's a new week and it's time for new
releases blood and wine is the second ad
on adventure for the witcher 3 wild hunt
going to be released on pc ps4 and xbox
one this 30 hour plus tale will
introduce the all-new in-game region of
Toussaint's and it will take Carol to Al
and untainted by war or an atmosphere of
carefree indulgent and nightly ritual
masks and ancient bloody secret the
expansion features new characters new
dangerous monster new armor new weapons
and a new went deck of cards it will
also introduce new gameplay mechanic
armor dying in addition to so-called
mutations and probably more sexiest
you're back in the saddle on the 31st as
part of the new hitman DLC out this week
we're getting a third entry in the
episodic release and it's taking us to
Marrakesh the gilded cage mission tasks
players with taking out private banker
Klaus strandberg who's tucked away in
the Swedish consulate the other target
is general Reza's aidan who's surrounded
by a buttload of soldiers in his
headquarters in town because of this
you're gonna see way more NPCs and live
areas through busy streets and market
good luck taking out your task it's up
to you agent 47 on the 31st back in 2011
your perfect vacation was ruined by a
bunch of man-eating zombies in bikinis
not a bad way to go this week we're
getting the definitive edition on ps4
and Xbox one with bonus zombies it
bundled the game with Riptide all DLC
and a 16-bit side-scrolling game called
Dead Island retro revenge Dead Island
definitive collection on ps4 will only
contain the original game on disk if you
want to play Riptide you'll have to
download it this is unique to ps4 though
both games are included on the xbox one
versions discs don't let them ruin your
island getaway you take them out on the
31st
also this week xbox one owners get the
very first one piece game ever one piece
burning blood the fighting game will be
coming out on ps4 Vita and the Xbox one
players will be able to create a team of
three characters to use swapping them in
and out for tactical advantages specific
characters will be able to use special
unique abilities called logia moves
players will also use logia guard which
grants them temporary immunity against
physical attacks by utilizing logia
fruits as in the manga devil fruits can
be used as a source of unique special
attacks and reinforced special attacks
become luffy on the 31st shadow warrior
developer flying wild hog is bringing
its formerly pc exclusive first person
shooter hard reset to ps4 xbox one and
pc as hard reset redux this week this
enhanced version of 2011 sci-fi FPS will
feature upgraded visuals rebalance
design new enemies and weapons like the
Shadow Warrior esque cyber katana
something to keep you busy while you
wait for Shadow Warrior 2 this comes out
on the 3rd finally dangerous golf is an
upcoming miniature golf game where you
try and cause the most destruction by
playing well miniature golf in a
confined space like a china shop or a
kitchen I mean you still want to get the
ball in the hole but that's pretty much
work golf in this game's similarities
end you're rewarded with making trick
shots and destroying as many objects in
the room as possible makes you wonder if
getting a birdie means getting it under
par or hitting an actual bird oh and
there's teleporters too because you know
putt putt for on the third so those are
all the games and dlc coming out this
week remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and they're
subject to change I'll see you next week
about
it reverbs it did it pick up on the mic